is there anything like you've like yet
to go
uh in terms of like videos for japan
because i feel like again like because i
think
the question came off the idea from it
yeah the question came up of like you
know because we finished doing across
japan three
and we were like oh is it gonna be
obviously i think after the last episode
goes up
i think next week yeah as of this
episode
if you get it done are you planning
another journey across japan
we're gonna get asked i do i might do
one day probably next year if i do it
again but like i like to just sort of do
individual episode challenges now a
series
it's a lot of pressure right because i
was like where's your next one whenever
i finish editing it
you know and it's you know it's quite
tricky to put a series out and then with
the series right everyone's like oh i
love the first episode then
oh the second episode has got the third
and then the fourth it's like is this
still going on then the fifth it's like
so like you kind of lose dwindle
generally a little bit you lose a bit
momentum yeah right
but it's kind of done alright this
series but you kind of like you just
think i'll just do a standalone episode
next time like
one like i did an episode where i went
to japan's most northern extreme point
this year that's just one episode 30
minutes long
and that was kind of fun i see you doing
more like stand alone almost like a
trash taste special
it's gonna steal your format except
what i want to know is like how much
planning goes into journey across japan
because it seems like
what's so funny why is he laughing just
picturing climbing krakatoa
it's
think it's erupted within our lifetime i
think you're talking about an event that
happened like 200 000 years ago chris
i actually don't know where you're
talking gonna find out we're gonna find
out if it happened two hundred thousand
years ago we probably wouldn't [ __ ]
call it a mountain anymore
you wouldn't know what it was like
a few times
you know how good of a youtube video
would have been if your volcano exploded
while you're in the
session it did explode didn't it after
we flew over it
later sakurajim is the most active
volcano in japan it smokes 24 hours a
day and then
about a week after we flew over it
actually erupted yeah and if we
our plane had been going over it it
would have been like just swatted out
the sky yeah
it was pretty [ __ ] scary yeah the
pilot was quite good he was like a
military pilot and that could be a great
video he was like
it's a barrel roll but like
yeah yeah yeah it was a little bit
dangerous like
a couple people died all right i'm
pretty sure that day
i hope so did you see someone die just
like we still filming this
we're still going guys in the town like
built right next to the volcano yeah
there's a there's lots of there's you
know thousands of people live around the
base
that feels like a bad idea it's pretty
safe the kids have to wear helmets to
protect them from ash and things but
it's like an acid bath and a electric
onsen that's what's the difference
between a spicy bath and a
active volcano it's like 10 to 100 ways
to kill yourself with glory this episode
isn't it
that's the taxes 100 ways to die
that's the title of this episode thank
you very much do they have a plan
for if the volcano goes off
far away enough from it but it used to
be an island sakurajima
and then it erupted and became a
peninsula because the lava just
connected with the land and built a land
bridge
so it's a pretty pretty hardcore okay
you know too much volcano some would say
asl it's not krakatoa isn't it stop
cracking it's not a crack at all
it's a racket sounds like a game show
you see krakatoa
why are you obsessed with [ __ ]
crackers it sounds cool
it's a cool sounding cracker yeah
because like you always seem to like
find some really like really out there
ideas cool ideas for
not just joining across japan but just
in general and these guys are talking
about how you literally
like [ __ ] scour google maps or
something yeah i mean
what goes into that well there's
definitely variables in jail across
japan like we
have a kind of start and end place we
have the hotel at the beginning of the
end
and then have a few locations lined up
um and then i sort of keep it from
in this season i kept it from joey
natsuki then we get challenges
then the challenges shape what happens
right so like the day we did the wrap
too much volcano we could have done
anything it could have been like
eat the worst food in kumamoto or you
know something like that so there's lots
of variables that keeps it
fresh and original but when you've got a
team of like five people
and you know it's a very pricey
experience to make you got to make sure
that
you're actually doing good things right
yeah you know so the various places are
planned out but i wouldn't say it's
scripted as such no no no i feel good
across japan three though was like
way more intense than two like i feel i
just feel like that week
of three was just we did i reckon twice
as much stuff as we did in two
years at least that's what it felt like
to me just ask myself how could you make
like the ultimate series in a week
and that's pretty much all the stuff i
found led to that so how long did it
take in total like
to find all those places oh i guess oh
it's like planned
and all that okay three days
three days 72 hours no i did actually
spend like two or three days just glued
to google like [ __ ] what is that i i
spend more time trying to plan my
[ __ ] holiday
you just planned an entire [ __ ]
special five like five day special
i think the greatest find was this
abandoned island called ikishima
um there's like a the abandoned island
everyone knows nagasaki's gunkanjima
battleship island which you've probably
seen
what because you can't [ __ ] do
anything there well yeah yeah we i
i thought you could walk around it but
you can only go 90 of it is blocked off
so she only goes at all and that was
going to be the centerpiece of the
series so once i discovered that i was
like we're [ __ ] and i got really
depressed and i was like is even worth
doing this series now the lost islands
it's not gonna work is it it's gonna be
the boring island so i kept looking
around nagasaki and i found
just 40 kilometers north another island
bigger ten times bigger than gunkanjima
30 abandoned buildings like a city a
mini city and
less than a hundred people and a hundred
yeah hundred percent people live there
and you can explore it freely it looks
really cool it did look really cool that
was my kind of
probably my favorite episode actually so
what's like your process of finding
these places because
i would like to know because like i you
know i i would like to travel around
more around japan but
i literally don't know where to [ __ ]
start like you do a google search about
cool places to go in japan you get like
the same
you should get the same 10 articles with
the same like
20 places every [ __ ] article you just
pick a place
like a place you want to go to and then
you start looking at everything around
the area right
well i'll switch to japanese use
japanese to search it gets a lot easier
right he's obviously the people that
know the places are going to be in japan
japanese and so if you do that you'll
find like 10 times more interested
places otherwise it's just always
tourists hot spots
yeah basically that's my advice get
someone who can speak japanese to look
up to these places
yeah joey joey planning the next trash
day special weekend
yeah sure